but I was that you are on the couch with
kind of nerd central what well now no
I'm not no Tina you've told about but
you yeah you do a lot of material about
growing up a nerd but you really weren't
yeah no I really was we've got
photographic evidence there you go this
will prove it oh I think that haircut
was done by folding my face in half it's
a guy from spinal tap who did it my mom
used to take me to a hair cutting school
because you could get like it's not good
literally a two dollar haircut and yeah
the guinea pig and the sign outside the
school said London Paris Upper Darby
he talked you've talked about your late
blossoming your a sort of sexual
awakening thank you for bringing that up
I was wanting to make sure everyone knew
yeah I was a late starter and yeah for
sure I don't I probably didn't see a
penis until I was least twenty and that
was probably a medical journal so like I
got a healthy penis
not modeled oh it's so horrible but then
but you this is so weird to be talking
this alone yeah would you you did leave
as I think you didn't do that physically
quite early again thank you
yeah no I've had been Kazim mr. Mendes
inbox offender yeah I did I was you know
wearing my heart as that haircut and
like a bra I'm I'm RJ my mom taking me
to JCPenney and and trying a bra on over
my clothes in the middle of JCPenney
just being like no no no it's like this
note there's no turning back for like 10
Hey the death is literally at the same
time like 1980 the same time that Kurt
was scaring men the streets of st. Louis
now smash cut to a JC Penney and
Josh we don't need to look for nerdy
pictures of you because they're in the
title sequence of your sitcom yeah he
was a little little boy oh that was my
Elton John face now this next one you
are such a high achiever here you are
look at that yeah what what competition
had you one second and third prizes I
think it was worth shell suit was it no
it was it was at the local village
Flower Show for flower arranging no just
whatever I can rise it was exacting that
wasn't expected what was that flower
arrangement you did yeah I did a flower
arrangement - well - um no you think you
came second and third yeah no I think
the other one was for there was a class
which was the best animal model made out
of vegetables my dad cheated and did it
yourself and still came third I don't
even got one more picture of you than
anything
Oh like a yelps Martina Navratilova
I love you I know and and that are you
bored of asking but if it is interesting
because 25 just came out blah blah blah
that you did co-write this this song
with Adele yes